for people who are not where they want
to be is that they have pain like Oodles
of pain and I remember when I was
starting out I was looking for passion I
was looking for purpose I was like I
just want to find something that I'm
motivated by versus saying like this is
terrible and because of this
terribleness I now have something that I
can run away from rather than not
looking at the knife or trying to take
painkillers to not feel the pain it's
completely sobering up taking the knife
and twisting it in your own heart and
being like I'm going to do
something about this it's not avoiding
pain it's choosing from the the very
beginning the Alchemy which is like you
have these terrible situations and you
have the opportunity to turn turn them
into Magic